what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and San Diego Comic-Con is right around
the corner we have a little over a month
left until the biggest Marvel event of
the Year San Diego comic-con's Hall h
panel and last year Marvel Studios gave
us a really big treat and a really big
surprise when they announced not only
all of phase five but a little bit of
phase six as well including two new
Avengers films and the release date
while the release date at the time of
the Fantastic Four MCU debut film now a
part of us wonder if they actually did
plan to reveal phase six last year at
sdcc a couple of days before San Diego
Comic-Con The Avengers titles did get
leaked so whether they plan to do it or
not or they did it because those leaks
came out and they wanted to jump ahead
of it we got it and it was awesome so
fans are wondering what exactly are we
going to be getting this year will it be
bigger will it be better Marvel Studios
has been making a lot of changes
recently and this has been due to
several different things mainly Kevin
feige the president of Marvel Studios
and Bob Iger the CEO of Disney currently
came out and basically stated hey we've
been doing kind of too much and we have
to scale back a little bit we're gonna
focus more on quality than quantity so
at San Diego Comic-Con are we about to
get a kind of rearrangement of Phase 5
and phase six of the MCU possibly plus
not to mention the wga rider strike
right now that has put a hold on several
Marvel Studios projects which could
result in some delays as well so one
thing to expect from Marvel Studios at
Hall h at sdcc is hopefully an updated
release date schedule there have been a
lot of talks from a lot of outlets
stating that some projects are indeed
going to get pushed back but we haven't
heard anything official from Marvel
Studios yet so we're looking at Marvel
to give us some clarification here on
what to expect as far as scheduling for
Phase 5 and phase six looking at them to
say okay hey here is the official
schedule because we all also at the same
time don't really know if some series
are going to get pushed back a year
they're rearranging them we've already
had a few rearrangements since sdcc of
last year so again just looking for
clarity for Marvel Studios which I do
believe they are going to provide and
this will most likely be for phase five
we only have three projects well four if
you count Deadpool 3 which of course we
do so four projects four phase six so
most of the updates about release dates
and scheduling and the order is going to
be about phase five now one other thing
that we are really looking forward to
does have to do with phase six it has to
do of course with the Fantastic Four
reports and rumors about the Fantastic
Four team have been going crazy lately
and it does seem right now currently
that we know who the Fantastic Four team
is but we haven't heard anything
official from Marvel Studios now
sometimes Marvel does events typically
online special events to where they
announce projects they've done this
before in the past where they've given
us the first trailers for Loki One
Division they announced that Kang is
going to be playing Kane the Conqueror
in these events in the past before that
were one-off special events but
currently Marvel Studios has no such
events planned and the next big one
which is the biggest one in the pop
culture fandom especially for Marvel is
sdcc so there we're looking to get an
update right now as it stands from what
we know from Insider reports Adam Driver
is our Mr Fantastic the role of Sue
storm has been offered to Margot Robbie
no news yet on whether or not that has
been officially accepted by her and a
contract has been formed yet Paul muskel
is apparently going to be playing the
Human Torch and apparently David Diggs
is going to be playing the human thing
now of course none of this has been
officially confirmed by Marvel but many
of the different insiders are all on the
same page about these actors having met
with Marvel Studios about the roles of
the Fantastic Four members and
negotiations have been in place with
them in Marvel Studios to play these
roles so it does seem like Marvel
Studios is trying to lock down their
team and most likely trying to do that
pretty quickly so they could make an
official announcement at San Diego
Comic-Con now it does seem like Kevin
feige does want to talk about the
Fantastic Four way back in 2019 which
was the last Comic-Con before last
year's of 2022. unfortunately there was
a two-year break due to the pandemic but
in 2019 at sdcc Hall h he did say one of
the very last things he said was they
didn't have time to talk about the
Fantastic Four since then we didn't
really hear anything else about it they
did do that one special event online
they did it because they weren't doing
sdcc that year where they simply
announced the movie was going into
development since then the only thing
we've heard was 2022 where they
announced the project again which we
already knew and gave us a release date
which has since changed but it does seem
like Kevin feige wants to talk about it
so the next step in talking about the
Fantastic Four would be to announce the
cast at least for our main Fantastic
Four family if we're lucky we might even
get a villain and possibly who's playing
that villain but that is probably going
to be held for later if it's going to be
a villain like Galactus or the Silver
Surfer Doom whoever it may be that's a
pretty big announcement along with the
casting announcement those are huge so
we'll probably only get one if we do in
fact get that casting announcement but
fingers crossed for that now of course
one of the biggest things that we expect
is the reveal the full reveal of phase
six like I said we have four projects so
far Deadpool 3 A Fantastic Four Avengers
the King Dynasty and Avengers Secret
Wars and there are so many projects that
Marvel has already confirmed or insiders
have reported about that could be a part
of phase six we have movies like Shang
Chi 2. this movie is confirmed by Marvel
Studios they have confirmed they are
making this film we also know that
doctor strange 3 is most likely going to
have to come before Avengers Secret
rewards because due to the ending of
doctor strange and the Multiverse of
Madness the post-credit scene with cleop
she said he caused an incursion to
happen and they have to fix it well
that's what secret Wars is going to be
about the Multiverse falling apart
incursions happening with different
universes all across the Multiverse so
that one's pretty much come in as well
we also have shows like the Wonder Man
series which is confirmed in the casting
has already taken place for it and also
Spider-Man 4 now typically Marvel
Studios does not go first when it comes
to announcing Spider-Man films typically
Sony handles that first however Sony has
recently come out and stated yeah they
are working on Spider-Man 4. Tom Holland
has come out and stated yep we've had
meetings we've had discussions but they
are now taking a break due to the wga
strike also Tom Holland is taking a
break from acting for a year so that's
on pause for a bit but the writing of
the script will continue eventually and
the movie should start shooting in a
year which means this will most likely
fall into phase six so this is probably
the biggest thing that we're looking
forward to with San Diego Comic-Con that
will actually happen we should be
getting the full reveal or at least a
lot more revealed about phase six of the
MCU and one thing that fans are really
curious about right now that we're not
sure if it's going to be addressed at
San Diego Comic-Con or not is the
current status of Jonathan Majors as
Kang the Conqueror this is something
that right now is truly up in the air we
do not know if Jonathan Majors is going
to continue to play King the Conqueror
in the MCU we have heard that Loki
season 2 has undergone some reshoots and
we've also heard that by the end of Loki
season 2 we will know the fate of
Jonathan majors and where he stands with
Marvel Studios the reshoots could have
been to film a scene where we see
different variants of Kang not played by
Jonathan Majors which would confirm that
Marvel Studios is probably moving on to
another actor now this was all due to
him getting arrested and now he's going
through trial right now to determine if
he is innocent or guilty of assault he's
already lost a lot of contracts a lot of
deals and everyone's kind of looking at
Marvel right now wondering what they're
going to do now but probably if this is
true just let the low-key season 2
finale or post credit scene tell us
what's gonna happen with him but maybe
they tell us a little bit about their
plans for this at San Diego Comic-Con
just to kind of tell us hey we do
acknowledge what's happening here's a
little bit of an answer or here's a full
answer or hey wait and see there's a lot
on both sides of the case but he has not
been proven innocent or guilty yet so a
lot could go down at San Diego Comic-Con
and a lot is going to go down no matter
what like I said this is the biggest
Marvel event of the Year Marvel Studios
always shows up we do know that people
like Charlie Cox and Vincent d'onoprio
and alaques are going to be showing up
to talk about the echo series about the
upcoming Daredevil series hopefully some
other awesome Marvel actors are going to
be showing up as well to talk about
their upcoming movies and shows and
again hopefully we get that fantastic
forecast hopefully they come they talk
about the Fantastic Port that would
probably be what I'm hoping for the most
but let me know what you are looking
forward to the most what you hope
happens at San Diego Comic-Con this year
and about a month away leave out your
thoughts down below and don't forget to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest Marvel news also if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
interested in our giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox series X a PlayStation 5
Marvel Legends items or some DC items we
pick one winner at the end of the month
and the winner gets to choose one item
if you'd love to support us even further
you can check out our patreon our
official website and our Discord server
also you can follow us on Instagram and
Twitter we'll link those all down below
and as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
foreign